[Musique]
dans le monde du cinéma les films
biographiques bien réussi peuvent être
synonyme de gros de très gros revenus
même si parfois ce qui est présenté dans
ses oeuvres ne correspond pas à la
vérité alors des informations une simple
liberté at-il dhabi parlons d'abord de
la popularité des biopics des films
biographiques sont indéniables
popularité qui se dément pas alexis
passe il faut comprendre que quand on
produit un film c'est un risque
financier comprend ouais c'est pas mal
plus facile d'inviter les gens à venir
dans les salles obscures pour voir une
histoire à propos d'une vedette que les
gens aiment et connaissent ils pensent
connaître ou pense que m exactement
parce que souvent ces vedettes relais de
cinéma ou de la musique on suit leur vie
dans les journaux à potins
mais on sait qu'il faut prendre les
journaux à potins avec un grain de sel
et c'est souvent le cas aussi avec les
films inspirés de vie devenaient tu te
donne quelques exemples où et allons-y
premier exemple le film bohemian
rhapsody entre premier exemple le
personnage de louis foster qui est
incarnée par mike myers dans le film
joue le rôle de l'employée de maison
disque crois pas du tout succès de
bohemian rhapsody dreamin rap se dit
bien ce personnage de bree forster il
n'est jamais aisé xavier lot créé de
toutes pièces
ils ont créé de toutes pièces par ce que
il y avait plusieurs personnes à
l'époque il disait le format la chanson
fonctionnera pas nécessairement alors
plutôt que de reprendre cinq vrais
personnages on est tous fusionné en un
personnage fit
deuxième exemple dans le même film
le grand concert live aid de concert
contre le sida ou le groupe dans le film
se reforme après avoir été séparé ne pas
s'être parlé durant des mois
mais là non plus c'est pas vrai parce
qu'ils avaient fait une tournée au
printemps précédent
ce que les goûts du groupe ausy plâtre
objectif n'était pas de faire une
biographie
film documentaire notre objectif c'était
de décaler la vie de freddie mercury
donc ils se sont laissé des libertés
comme ça comparez claquer le groupe pour
que ce soit plus grave autre exemple
d'allier je suis vraiment content qu'il
nous en parle j'ai adoré ce film amadeus
un autre cas ou encore une fois les
faits ont été absolument dans le film on
exacerbe la haine entre salieri est
mauvais mais je comprends que ce film là
est basé sur une pièce de théâtre de
peter schaefer qui elle-même basée sur
une tragédie de pouchkine et tout le
monde s'entend pour dire que c'est pas
la vraie histoire ce qu'ils voulaient
faire c'était repartir de ces deux
grands rôles et de créer une rivalité de
toutes pièces si on veut entre le génie
et la personne qui a simplement du
talent en co2 et et je marque dans
l'imaginaire collectif
ce qu'on a retenu c'est que céline riffs
était le méchant jaloux qui empoisonnent
et mazars fait sur lequel la plupart des
historiens des musicologues ont des gros
gros gros bémol les puristes de mozart
en privé ça ressemble à celle que c'est
simplement pas la vérité et pourtant
c'est ça qu'on arrête n'y resta le monde
de la musique un peu plus près de notre
époque
elton john rocket man annonce un film
sorti cette année fait bockel elton john
a été associé lui même mais malgré tout
il ya des petites d'inexactitudes au
niveau de fait tout seul comme par
exemple le choix de son nom le tsunami
en six mois
[Musique]
tiens enjoy le nom viendrait en fait de
lord john ball wii qui est un musicien
très populaire sur la scène anglaise
à l'époque ces deux là que viendra le
nom elton john et non pas de john lennon
mais sans doute que pour le grand public
langdon ballerines cei doit pas grand
chose on a quelques minutes on veut que
les gens comprennent facilement on se
dit que je me donne tout le monde sait
qui allons-y pour le raccourci c'est pas
des documentaires c'est des biopics
c'est une évocation de la vie des
artistes qui voit la vie quelqu'un qui
on veut en retenir une impression moi ce
que je vous propose c'est de prendre ces
femmes là pour ce qu'ils sont des
oeuvres d'art utilisez un deuxième écran
si vous n'êtes pas au cinéma pour aller
contre vérifier les faits et quoi qu'il
en soit si c'est une façon pour vous de
découvrir des artistes tous importants
que queen qu'elton john utaka mozart et
bien c'est biopic auront fait leur
travail voilà ce que mon cinéma de
mourir si bon cinéma